[Music]
it's Gwen right Gwen Taylor Teddy Teddy
miles this is my
place look I know it looks as if the
damn Adams Family used to live here but
trust me this place is
harmless really got to get this thing
fixed oh boy now we got 20 cabins all
basically
identical if you take to the job then
maybe we can make it a regular thing
right it'd be great what kind of
security do you have here security well
if you want there's a fire axe next to
the vending machine nobody's going to
mess with you if you swinging that thing
around you know what I'm saying welcome
to the night shift excuse
me are you okay you know this place is
haunted right oh my God how does this
dump even stay open people probably died
here right in other news authorities
have yet to apprehend a convicted
murderer who escaped a facility
Wednesday
evening it's for
you are you going to show me to my
[Music]
room
for